hello guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
Jerry and I today are gonna respond to
you guys that's right that's right as we
predicted we would get a lot of dislikes
on our Batman V Superman trailer
reaction review of the second trailer
very vocal comments yeah and we you know
we try to keep these videos at least
under 15 minutes mainly because of a
copyright strike you can imagine why we
got one of those we wanted to you know
going a little bit more depth and
explain a little things because some
people I feel like there are people who
really got what we were saying yeah and
then there are some people who I'm like
you're really not getting what I'm
saying it's like it's one thing if
you're attacking me with directly about
what I said it's another thing where I'm
like well no no no you just don't
understand what I'm saying actually you
know in good faith trying to bridge the
gap because the truth of the matter is
like this trailer didn't make me go off
[ __ ] this movie now I'm just a little
less excited than I would have for and I
mean this isn't my favorite kind of
cinema anyway the first trailer I was
pleasantly surprised I was like yeah I
think I will check that out and then
this trailer is like oh you know it's
not like let's cover some specifics I
would like you to take care of this one
the destruction of the cities you know
you made a comment about that yeah a lot
of people make the comment about so many
people died and there's a
counter-argument of well he saved the
world so yeah a few people have to die
and what's the other thing people are
saying that happens all the time in
comic books yes yes here's my thing
about that it's just a detail that kind
of takes away from it for me it's not
something I sit around all day going you
know it's like the first man of steel
started to lose me in the second half
because the action is so huge and
there's so much of it these two
invincible guys are fighting each other
they destroy so much of Metropolis and
so many people must have died in that
fight and the difference for me is that
you know you're watching spider-man it
seems like spider-man is trying to
prevent people from dying while he's
fighting both concerns are there yeah
some might argue well what about that
moment with general zod you know where
he ended up snapping his neck Superman
was trying to save some people at that
time he's fighting for the better cause
so like yeah he is trying to save people
it's just like for summary
maybe it's the performance or maybe it's
just the amount of destruction
yeah buying with the performance I just
never got the sense that Superman really
cared that much about people not that
that shouldn't happen in movies it's
more about the feeling of the character
feeling a little bit of like you know a
little bad about what happened it's like
it's harder for me to be on board with
Superman in that movie because I'm like
do you care like it's it's an
interesting idea to think about if they
want it to be that way because this
Superman is more emotionally repressed
stuff it's not about that the
destruction of the city shouldn't be
there it's like we all love [ __ ] like
that
but we also like it when there's a
little bit of the emotional context of
like people are dying yeah it would be
nice of Superman at least cared about
because then he's not like a hero if he
doesn't care and I gotta say the number
one thing we're getting in the comments
when this destruction thing got brought
up everyone started being like oh you
know what people say this about DC but
you here's how you guys probably feel
about Marvel like and I'm like what we
never mentioned once the word Marvel or
any Marvel related characters if we have
an it to pick with a non Marvel comic
book movie it doesn't mean that we just
want to suck marvel's dick oh yeah we
love the Dark Knight like to to varying
degrees we love Nolan's Batman trilogy
those are technically DC's movies we
even did a whole podcast called haters
why we love The Dark Knight Rises yeah
and like you know I will fully admit
like I'm not a comic book expert I'm
coming toward this as you know a movie
fan more I don't go apeshit for Marvel
movies and they're acting like we've a
lot of our source [ __ ] yeah like you can
have a tempered opinion about something
there are things I like about Marvel
movies and there are a lot of things
that I don't like about Marvel movies at
least contextually cuz I guess the main
complaint is when that happens in a
Marvel movie no one seems to [ __ ] I
guess I guess yeah they there's more
eyes on DC I guess it's it's the wrong
juxtaposition because everybody wants
this to succeed so much because DC is
sort of struggling to figure this you
know paradigm out so it's not a nitpick
against DC it's you know it's it's just
what I have to go on based on what they
gave me the other big complaint that
people haven't seen is
well of course they're gonna have to
work together in the end every true to
Justice League it's in the synopsis okay
here's what I gotta say to that alright
we know it's like yeah I never said like
we don't it's like obviously it's going
to happen but here's the thing we didn't
know for sure if it's gonna happen in
this movie the other thing is and and
and even just to cover that base you it
still is would see we've been very
possible even if it might not surely
happen it seems like a likelihood you
know it's called Batman V Superman yeah
I want the focus to be about Batman vs
Superman I don't want to be sitting
there going oh wait now I'm just there
eventually gonna get along so this
tension goes away because now I'm not so
invested in them fighting each other
because we know for sure they're gonna
resolve it I think of Captain America
the civil war trailer here's my point if
we saw Tony Stark and Steve Rogers
getting along in the trailer after the
war yeah it's like well what's the
[ __ ] point of this we know it's gonna
happen that are gonna team up for the
third Avengers movie if they showed it
it would [ __ ] suck and that's why I
feel about this well because that's hear
me out on this it's like you can't turn
your movies trailer into an
advertisement for the next movie in that
same trailer because the thing that bugs
me about that decision is the trailer
begins with Alfred or somebody being
like we might not be able to get through
this or this might be the end you know
some kind of grim phrase and then by the
end of the trailer the trailer goes no
actually it's not there they're gonna
work together yeah even if it's a
foregone conclusion don't just give it
to me in the trailer because it's like
we said in the video it feels like
you've seen the whole movie now it's
like now the suspense of what they're
gonna do to each other isn't gonna be
that great because you know it's not
gonna be enough to kill them or end
their relationship the other thing
that's written on understanding I'm
saying I specifically said Wonder
Woman's introduction I don't know if
that's her first scene in the movie I
know she was briefly featured in the
other trailer yeah for like a split
second I know but here's the thing that
was still at the end of the day her
introduction to meeting Batman and
Superman upon saving them from doomsday
yeah
that's a pretty big reveal to be like
that's a good facial yes we know they're
gonna meet we totally just that's gonna
be a distinct moment for that character
in the movie yeah that's like you just
don't show that part it's not about the
ending it's not about the end result but
if you give away too much of what the
journeys like then it kind of doesn't
even matter
you know you already know yeah it's like
that's the thing about I mean I wonder
if I mean cause we'd remark to it it
kind of gets jokey at that point maybe
if they I fully admit if they've just
given us a different Wonder Woman
introductory scene maybe I want to be
like ah but for where I'm sitting right
now I even from a marketing standpoint I
feel like it ruins some of the
anticipation to show that because that's
gonna be a moment we're gonna be excited
to see and I feel like seeing it on a
big screen in the actual movie
experience is the most important place
for that moment you know it's like
people are already gonna see this
let's have that surprise and that's what
scares me about movies now is we want
more stuff ahead of time and we don't
like to anticipate an anticipation of
the fun of it and when we say surprise
we don't mean we didn't know what was
going to happen I really don't want
people to think that's what we're saying
people have this impression that because
they gave they showed something in the
trailer and were like bummed out that
they showed it yeah
that people think oh my god these guys
are idiots they didn't know that was
gonna happen when they're now not about
that the Wonder Woman news I mean we may
have talked about it on one of these
shows even yeah like I was worried about
that idea in and of itself to be like we
got Batman vs Superman that's crazy and
we're throwing in Wonder Woman yeah had
a whole discussion about how like I hope
they handle that or any others Aquaman's
like things like we haven't seen Aquaman
yet and I know that and there's other
characters we haven't seen yet so yeah
there's still some super but it's like
and they shouldn't have shown doomsday I
really don't think they should have
showed him I think you get away with it
no that's for me that that takes away
from the Batman V Superman part I want
that to be the main focus I don't care
if a star getting along in the end I
want that to be the main it's the most
interesting part of this story is these
two going toe-to-toe I agree with what
you're saying but I think that
piggybacks like I think you can show
doomsday you just can't show them
fighting him together because doomsday
is one of Superman's ultimate villains
yeah we got Batman V Superman now
there's already the distraction of one
durable
now there's already the other thing of
Aquaman's in here okay now we got one of
Superman's biggest villains here and
we're introducing Lex Luthor it's too
much well and then it goes you like you
better stick this landing otherwise is
gonna seem like you rushed all this to
get to Justice League to fight the
Avengers yeah they can probably pull off
him being in the movie yeah
but the trailer I felt like they should
have like Godzilla did a little bit well
I mean just just as an aesthetic thing
like if they only show doomsday like in
parts or obscured by things so that
you're more just seeing the power of
doomsday like so you don't quite know
what he looks like he's gonna be capable
like that can still be cool in a trailer
to drive up the mystery but to just show
him turn around and blow something up is
like oh I don't have the biggest issue
with that I just still feel like patient
like it's it goes back to the whole
thing I hate of people saying like oh
because it's there though it's like yes
I know that's gonna be okay the Star
Wars trailers the need for the new one
they haven't shown Luke Skywalker once
yet they haven't shown Luke now is Luke
gonna be in the film we all [ __ ] know
that but we don't want them to show us
Luke yeah just having the question of
like wait wait where's Luke are we gonna
see that did something happen to Luke is
Luke not coming back that will bring
people into the theater and it gives us
something fun to speculate about
beforehand yeah it's what you're
choosing it's the image you're choosing
to leave us with if you want the image
you're trying to sell us Batman vs
Superman with if you want that image to
be well they're gonna get along at the
end don't call it Batman B's yeah that's
like that man and Superman you know
advertise that part of it you know
because hey maybe Batman vs Superman
doesn't it doesn't pick a side or a
conclusion no no what is what it should
do what what it should do is do what a
good prequel does which is when that
fights happening one they're going
toe-to-toe with each other to really
feel like one of them's going to lose
yeah one of them might die and no sighs
that yeah it's like even though we know
it's like a good prequel you know it's
like sometimes we know what's gonna
happen many comic book movies follow
similar structures it's like we all know
these are giant franchises that are
gonna continue they're probably gonna
make it through and bond together every
fifth movie they'll kill somebody who's
contract is up but
really like we all know these are gonna
be made to continue forever yeah yeah
exactly now so we're not being naive
it's just like it would be nice if the
trailer focused on Batman vs Superman
and not go but it's alright it doesn't
matter it doesn't really matter like
yeah yeah the idea is it should still
have us be in the theater I feel like
someone's gonna die right now I feel
like someone might actually die what's
the outcome it's like even though you
know you should still be in the theater
going one of them you know bring you in
with that question yeah if that's the
title boy oh boy
yeah you know give it away like pitching
somebody you're moving you end the pitch
with but it doesn't really matter though
because the next movie like yeah it
takes away from it it's all I want to
enjoy this movie because this is the one
I'm gonna see in a few months
yeah I want to see the main focus of
these two not getting along I don't care
for at ease to Justice League and this
the thing is the first two-thirds of
this trailer I was pretty psyched about
I was like so it looks cool Clark and
Bruce look like they're they got a cool
tension going on Lex Luthor's really
colorful like this is all pretty cool
like there's still cool [ __ ] about this
trailer it does some things you know it
seems to do some things right or like it
could do some things right and inspires
that confidence about certain things and
I just raises questions about others I
have to say like what I said about Ben
Affleck I saw the trailer again I
actually think Ben athletes doing a much
better job than the first time I saw now
that I was over just sipping a bit I was
like I was like nah man he's [ __ ]
Bruce way yeah he's Bruce Wayne my
opinion on that has changed and the
other thing that the last thing that
people like pointed out was I was asking
about Batman's voice for time because of
the 15 minute and all I have to cut out
the part where we re-establish that's a
voice modulator and that I was kind of
be more specific thinking like he was
not just the voice modulator but that he
was also doing a voice as well yeah it
was it kind of sounded like that and
that was a question I had not alike it
yeah it's something about it don't
honesty I'm still gonna be there like
opening night first show I'm still gonna
be psyched to see it it's more about the
aggression towards the marketing at the
end of the day than it is the film
itself we mean I judge the film itself
because it's just a trailer it's more
towards the more
getting of the trailer yeah it's what
what makes what builds the anticipation
and what makes you want to go see it you
know and it's like the movie could end
up totally different and I would love
that
no that's it no I would love to be blown
away by this movie the movie could find
really great of ways of making me think
one of them's gonna die even though I
know they're not gonna die and you know
I could get lost in that but you know I
mean at the end of day it's called
Batman V Superman this particular
chapter is not about going how do Batman
and Superman team up yeah this is about
Batman vs Superman and it's like well if
we know they're gonna team up in my
argument to you what the [ __ ] is the
point of making this then just make
Justice League yeah if you think this is
all like pointless to be upset about
it's like they went it's like it's it's
like an a prequel before the the main
movie I'm out almost the movie might not
entirely be necessary and they are not a
good thing to do like you guys in every
movie like it's necessary and to go at
the end hey that thing that's in the
title and don't worry about that that
makes it seem like this movie is just a
perfunctory like happy we got to make
this one yeah anyway guys listen um if
you still like us click this button your
subscriber it's as to how this came out
reasons - jerr-bear didn't guest up
supposed to by said jer-bear yeah on
this channel follow us on our social
networks
oh follow me on you now the real Ryan
Wright you now follow me it's an app
it's kind of like periscope and away on
Sunday you got a very special livestream
I'm gonna do you don't want to follow me
on that I trust me I don't want to give
it away but you're gonna want to Ned for
sure